are you doing I'm doing tricep dips dude
ever heard of him are you serious man oh
I bet I could do Gabby sit-ups right now
let's keep watching this movie while we
play Oh this movie scene yes I've been
kind of seeing this girl yeah no that's
cool I mean I've just been hooking up so
oh really I'm I mean I've been hooking
up too
still I've actually hooked up with every
one of his bar
that's weird I also have hooked up with
everyone oh really so you know what you
know Theresa yeah Tracy's a great girl
this song right here oh yeah I like it
but it's not old you know this song came
out like two weeks ago I'm going to like
underground stuff that you probably have
never heard of DJ sweet'n low he's all
right off-key mm sometimes
up top when I'm in the right mood and
this splinter and my fingers just
killing me one time I was straight
hammering and I hammered a nail right
through my hand
I actually just snapped my whole arm
trying to rescue this three year old
girl I took a bullet for my grandfather
three actually I actually broke my ankle
while I broke a record for our track
team I think I'm done after this one oh
really
yeah good I'm gonna go for a few more
you know really about really good yeah I
feel like add either penis penis penis
penis penis penis now she's looking over
at me come on she's looking at me who's
the better dancer come on blank rapper
I'm proud yeah you look tired if you do
this for hours ugh yeah my abs are good
give me another shot
penis Hey
this say that yes yes penis penis
I want you penis